We'll probably never know the reasons for
the death of every character who's died on
a TV show, but some stories from the behind
the scenes just couldn't stay under wraps.
Here are some of the most scandalous reasons
some well-known TV characters kicked the fictional
bucket.
Shannen Doherty is arguably better known for
being difficult to work with than she is for
her acting. After Tori Spelling witnessed
what looked like a fistfight between her and
Jennie Garth on the set of 90201, she asked
her father, producer Aaron Spelling, to fire
Doherty.
Just a few years later, however, Aaron Spelling
surprisingly cast Doherty in another project,
the WB supernatural drama Charmed. History
repeated itself: Doherty quit the show in
2001 after reports of a feud with co-star
Alyssa Milano. After a season three cliffhanger
that left her character's fate in jeopardy,
the season four opener revealed that the character
had died.
"I don't understand why magic can't fix this,
and why it can't bring Prue back. It's not
like we haven't cheated death before. I don't
understand why this time is any different."
T. R. Knight left Grey's Anatomy in 2009 after
five seasons despite the fact that his character,
young doctor George O'Malley, was a fan favorite.
Knight knew something was up with the show's
first nine episodes of the 2008-09 season
when he landed only 48 minutes of screen time,
less than half of co-star Sandra Oh. Rather
than ask producer Shonda Rhimes just what
was happening, he walked away instead. He
told Entertainment Weekly,
Perhaps he angered Rhimes. His horrific death
could certainly imply that: He's hit by a
bus, admitted to the very hospital where he
worked, and, after his doctor friends finally
recognize him, he's pronounced brain-dead
and passes away.
One of the biggest new shows of the 2004-05
season was also among the most innovative:
ABC's time- and mind-bending desert island
sci-fi adventure series Lost. Many of its
cast became stars, and the show won the Emmy
for Outstanding Drama Series. But some actors
on the show didn't enjoy the process of making
the series. Adewale Akinnuoye-Agbaje, who
played the mysterious and conflicted Nigerian
priest Mr. Eko, left the series in Season
3. Why? Well, while this might be hard to
believe, Akinnuoye-Agbaje hated filming in
Hawaii. He asked to leave the show, and long-term
plans for Mr. Eko were cancelled. The character
was killed off, a victim of the Smoke Monster
"The Lord is my shepherd, I shall not want.
The Lord is my shepherd…"
Eko wasn't the only character killed off the
beloved sci-fi show. From the outside, it
appeared that Lost characters Ana Lucia Cortez
and Libby Smith, portrayed by Michelle Rodriguez
and Cynthia Watros, met their ends due to
offscreen misbehavior. During the middle of
the show's second season, both actresses were
arrested on suspicion of drunk driving and
failed sobriety tests. Not long after, both
characters died.
In actuality, the arrests didn't affect the
show at all. In an interview with TV Guide,
Lost co-creator Damon Lindelof said that the
characters' deaths had already been written.
In the case of Ana Lucia Cortez, Michelle
Rodriguez only wanted to do one season of
the show anyhow. The fact that her character
also happened to die at the same time as Watros'
Libby was just a coincidence.
Seinfeld's occasional callous cruelty was
part of the appeal of the show, but the show
outdid itself in one episode when it killed
off a major recurring character. George Costanza's
fiancée, Susan Ross, died at the end of the
seventh season, having ingested a toxic amount
of glue from licking wedding invitation envelopes.
"So, she's dead."
"Yes."
"Huh."
Apparently, George, who'd wanted out of the
engagement, wasn't the only one happy to hear
the news of the character's death. In an interview
with Howard Stern several years later, actor
Jason Alexander revealed that actress Heidi
Swedberg just didn't sync up with him:
"Her instincts for doing a scene, where the
comedy was, and mine were always misfiring."
He wasn't the only one on set who felt that
way. Alexander related how his co-star Julia
Louis-Dreyfus agreed with him, casually remarking:
Once writer Larry David heard this, that was
the end of Susan Ross.
Poor Carla Tortelli. Just when it looked like
she'd finally found true love with hockey
player Eddie LeBec, the poor doofus went and
got himself killed. While Cheers was generally
one of the more reserved comedies on television
during its 11-year run, the writers scratched
their wacky itch when it came time to kill
Eddie. He's killed in a bizarre Zamboni accident,
setting up a wacky chain of events that led
to Carla meeting Eddie's secret other wife
during the funeral. In 2006, Cheers writer
Ken Levine revealed on his blog just why they
killed off Eddie LeBec, and in such a perplexing
way. Actor Jay Thomas, who also worked as
a radio DJ, responded to a caller who asked
him how it felt to act on Cheers. Levine recalled
Thomas making some distasteful remarks about
his co-star.
That got him fired, and it got Levine and
writing partner David Isaacs to write Eddie
LeBec's bizarre death.
While House had its lighter moments, it could
get pretty dark too. One example: the fate
of eager diagnostic medicine fellow Lawrence
Kutner. The character had to make a hasty
exit when actor Kal Penn embarked on a political
career partway through the show's run in 2009,
taking a job with the brand-new Obama administration.
Not wanting to pass up the opportunity to
wring a bit of drama out of his departure,
the show's writers opted to have Kutner commit
suicide. Chilling as that end may have been,
it seems that there were no hard feelings
between the actor and the showrunners. Penn
came back to reprise his role as Kutner for
House's series finale in the form of a hallucination.
The only character to appear in every episode
of the original Dallas, J. R. Ewing was famously
shot in the cliffhanger episode "A House Divided,"
which left America wondering "Who Shot J.R.?"
all summer. Though he survived that assassination
attempt, a second shooter finally felled the
infamous oilman during the second season of
the series' 2010s revival on TNT. While that
plot twist could have served as a shocking
and clever callback to the original show's
most famous moment, writers had to include
it out of necessity. Larry Hagman, who played
J.R. Ewing on both series, lost his battle
to cancer in November 2012. Dallas 2.0 was
still in production, forcing the creative
staff to both explain his sudden absence while
also hurriedly writing the character off the
show. The end came with "The Furious and the
Fast," which aired several months after Hagman's
death, and used pre-existing footage to cobble
together his character's exit story.
John Francis Daley was part of the cast of
Fox's long-running procedural drama Bones
from almost the beginning, but not until the
end. As Dr. Lance Sweets, Daley played a psychologist
and behavior expert who helped the crime fighters
of the series in their investigations. Over
the years, Daley developed a second career
as one of the most sought-after comedy screenwriters
in Hollywood, working on the scripts for Horrible
Bosses, The Incredible Burt Wonderstone, and
Cloudy with a Chance of Meatballs 2. In 2014,
Daley was offered the chance to not only write
the new National Lampoon's Vacation, but to
direct it as well. Daley asked for a few months
off from Bones to do the movie, but the writers
couldn't think of a good way to explain a
prolonged absence. So his character took a
bullet from a bad guy and died.
Josh Charles was a huge part of why The Good
Wife turned in such compelling drama each
week. His character, Will Gardner, was a brilliant
attorney in the show's courtroom scenes, and
he was also a foil and romantic interest for
Alicia Florrick. That and the fact that The
Good Wife didn't usually contain a lot of
violence meant it was pretty shocking when
Will was brutally shot in a courtroom scene
in a 2014 episode.
"He needs help."
"Will! Paramedics!"
But creators Robert and Michelle King didn't
have any animosity toward Charles. Before
the 2013-14 season began, Charles knew his
contract would be up, and he let the Kings
know that he wanted to move on, allowing them
to plan an explosive exit for Will. Charles
explained it all on The Late Show with David
Letterman:
Character deaths were a semi-regular occurrence
on Scandal. Anyone who got caught up in the
high crimes and political machinations of
Olivia Pope generally saw their lifespan decrease
by a few years. That included her fellow fixers
like Harrison Wright, played by Columbus Short.
Like so many other Scandal standouts, he went
and got himself killed by Olivia's evil father
Eli Pope, a top-secret CIA operative. At the
end of season three of Scandal, Harrison finds
out Eli killed the president' son, and it
doesn't end well for Harrison.
In April 2014, just days after the episode
aired, Short assured viewers that his character
was really dead: He'd quit the show. After
enduring a series of legal problems, Short
admitted on Access Hollywood Live that he'd
left Scandal due to a drug issue.
Even after more than 30 years, Shelley Long
is still best known for her role as Diane
Chambers on Cheers, a show she famously left
in 1987 for a film career. She never became
an A-list movie star, but she found one of
her most memorable gigs in the recurring role
of DeDe Pritchett, the emotionally distant
mother of Claire and Mitchell on Modern Family.
Long prominently bowed out of this show, too,
although this time it wasn't her idea, the
Modern Family writers just wanted to explore
the effects of death on the family. Before
the beginning of Modern Family's tenth season
in 2018, show co-creator Christopher Lloyd
told Entertainment Weekly that a significant
character on the show would die.
On the show's Halloween episode, Claire gets
a call from her stepfather in which she learns
that DeDee Pritchett died in her sleep. The
rest of the episode delves into that impact:
"Okay, how are we gonna handle this?"
"You mean because the two most emotionally
complicated people on earth are facing the
loss of the most complicated relationship
of their lives?"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't miss
a single one.